parfois je me dis qu'est-ce que ça
ferait tu vois pour moi d'avoir une vie
entre guillemets normale ou je vais à
l'école et je vis ma vie je rentre le
soir je pense qu'elle est pas normale
si elle est normale pour moi je
m'entraîne environ ouais 5 à 6 jours par
semaine entre 4 et 8 heures par jour ça
dépend en fonction des sciences comme
quelqu'un va aller travailler le matin
ben moi je suis allé grimper
Floriane Bertone du coup et je vous
emmène du coup pour faire une séance
d'entraînement avec moi
j'en fais mais je passe ma vie en faire
des choses ah mais j'entends toujours
tes mots fléchés sur toi
bien sûr quand je m'ennuie ou que j'ai
du temps et tout je kiffe faire ça fait
un peu mamie mais c'est marrant j'aime
beaucoup
c'est réglé aujourd'hui ça aurait été
beaucoup plus technique il y a pas
d'histoire de je fais de la grimpe avec
les bras
j'ai la chance de pouvoir vivre de ça
vivre de ce que j'aime et je me lève le
matin et j'ai toujours envie de le faire
et le jour où j'aimerais plus je me
forcerai pas à faire je vais me prendre
pas mal de chutes assez drôle donc film
bien c'est cool j'ai les gens assez
abîmés de ces trucs tu vois
faut pas avoir peur faut pas avoir peur
j'ai commencé quand j'avais 8 ans donc
ça fait 10 ans déjà pile que que j'ai
commencé mon frère et ma sœur on en fait
beaucoup mon frère est franchit toujours
actuellement ma sœur elle a choisi des
études moi non j'ai toujours été
beaucoup beaucoup décalé c'est à dire
que j'ai tout de suite tout de suite
aimé beaucoup le sport j'ai tout de
suite aimé des choses qui étaient pas
forcément aimées par le grand public et
donc à l'école c'était pas facile pour
moi des
ma plus petite jeunesse en fait c'était
pas évident donc c'est vrai que ça m'a
un peu sauvé j'avais commencé à 16 ans
du coup les coupes du monde donc j'étais
un peu en voyage partout c'était un peu
compliqué pour moi d'étudier et de faire
le sport en même temps ça a été vraiment
compliqué de s'y décider et de
l'accepter mais on a décidé d'arrêter du
coup les cours et de se concentrer pour
le moment principalement sur le sport et
on reverra pour pour la suite
j'avais pas envie de regretter j'avais
envie de me donner à 100% dans quelque
chose et pas regretter parce que je sais
que bah si j'avais fait l'école et le
sport si j'avais décidé à la fin de
faire l'école je pense que j'y serai pas
allé à 100 % j'aurais regretté et pareil
pour le sport quoi je suis jeune et je
suis pas jeune toute ma vie donc donc
j'ai décidé de voilà de foncer et puis
on verra quoi
et si je dis
bien ça
ok
les vrais Jobs tu vas bien Instagram
pour Bruce mais là j'avoue que va
falloir faire avec je suis désolé ça
variété du coup j'aime pas trop faire
que par le cul du panneaux que toute la
dame que il peut être beaucoup de choses
quoi
c'est moins bon pour l'entraînement mais
disons que mais c'est plus faible
monte maintenant
quand tu réussis truc ça paraît
facilement
tu as mis 4 heures effectivement ça fait
un peu peur tu as peur de se taper des
gens tu n'as pas que peur des fois
en compétition tu seras rarement dans
des extrêmes comme ça prends le temps on
le sent bien en bas
[Musique]
je peux passer directement
ok je sais qu'il est très fort dans ce
style mais c'est plus fans
pour vous j'ai aucune tolérance aux gens
qui se plaignent sur l'entraînement de
haut niveau en escalade
si vous viviez 90% du taux de sport
vachement moins drôle que que nous on
a oui il y a pas de place à se plaindre
tellement c'est une équipe
pour l'instant tu peux être fatigué tu
peux y aller il y a des périodes ou tu
es pas bien il y a beaucoup de gens qui
posent des choses sur tes épaules et tu
as pas envie de les décevoir en fait
il y a beaucoup de choses que tu peux
gérer comme l'alimentation quelle heure
tu te couches quelle heure tu te lèves
qu'est-ce que tu fais avant de grimper
le téléphone ou ça c'est des choses en
fait qui peuvent te prendre de l'énergie
inutilement
[Musique]
ça fait trop mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
surtout quand on travaille des trucs
durs c'est la répétition quoi que tu
fais tout le temps le même monde et des
fois tu sais pas pourquoi ça marche pas
des fois c'est peut-être changer ça ça
marche pas tes frustré ne force pas en
fait
je peux pas dire je suis fatigué
vraiment
aujourd'hui je suis dans un bon mood
donc j'arrive bien j'arrive pas à
prendre assez sur moi mais il y a des
jours où ça a trop horrible je suis pas
réussir à bien contrôler j'ai je vais
être très très éparpillé je ferai ça me
concentrer on est ça quand même mettre
le plus simple parce que enfin c'est
l'entraînement quoi ça fait partie du
jeu et si on est fort à l'entraînement
c'est qu'on travaille pas les bonnes
choses
parce que tu es venu chercher le
poisson
l'objectif c'est de se faire très tarder
la gueule pour que quand tu arrives au
compet et tu tombes sur les trucs qui
sont plus faciles tu sois capable de les
faire en randonnant mais notre mot je
l'ai fait mais c'était mille fois plus
dur je me suis fait lever mais j'ai pas
levé ça dans le mouvant un peu là en
fait je le fais mais
tu vois et l'objectif en fait c'est ça
en théorie c'est d'être capable de faire
d'attendre un niveau tellement élevé que
l'on peut pas être bah ça vous paraît
d'être mille fois plus facile que ce
soit
[Musique]
c'est la fin c'est la fin c'est comme ça
qu'on finisse 92 % de l'essence
on peut très rare les uns sont vraiment
il y a eu des
des
vraies une fois ce serait cool la
qualification 2 ça ira honnête ça reste
un vrai objectif maintenant voilà il me
reste du temps je sais que j'ai encore
pas mal de marge de progression surtout
pour atteindre en tout cas le niveau que
moi je voudrais avoir disons que c'est
que le début